besides the channel and the good looks
what am I famous for the Vienna what am
I famous for the Run Gotham chess knows
how satisfying it is to sacrifice The
Rook The Rook is the second most
powerful piece on the board worth five
points of material sacrificing your Rook
is a big investment one only justified
by a fierce attack we've compiled the
top five times a professional players
sacrificed their rook in a game
our first game is from over 100 years
ago the game was played in 1922 into
plits show now Germany between Geza
maroxi and Sevilla tartikauer names that
will sound familiar to well-studied
chess players Roxy was 17 years hard to
cower senior so this was a game between
distinct chess Generations Roxy was
known for his conservative defensive
style of play in the maroxy bind Bears
his name tartikauer was a talented
player known for his personality off the
board famous at the time for his witty
chess aphorisms such as the winner of
the game is the player who makes the
next to last mistake
this game was a perfect reflection of
the players the young Brash Larger than
Life tartik hour against the older solid
maroxy tartikauer put on an attacking
master class with the black pieces that
featured the sacrifice of both his Rooks
in this seemingly quiet position
tartikauer played perhaps the most
famous Rook sacrifice ever with Rook
takes H2 allowing the queen to begin a
long-term attack with Queen takes F2
after the king recaptured in the short
term this was a rook sacrifice for three
pawns but in the long term it would open
up the white king for a devastating
attack to give up this much material for
an advantage that isn't immediately
obvious is what makes this one of the
greatest Rook sacrifices of all time
fast forward a few moves and we arrive
here
maroxy has given back some material and
tartikauer is compelled to sacrifice
again he plays Rook takes F1 check which
is sacrificing a rook for a bishop so
technically an exchange sack
white only has two legal moves to
recapture with the king or the queen if
the queen recaptures black has mate with
Queen H2 and tartikauer's idea after
King takes is the clever E5 opening up
the bishop diagonal to pin the queen to
the King this is spotted by maroxy of
course and he steps out of the pin but
after the final black piece joins the
attacking party it is Unstoppable
after this check maroxy resigned
here once again white has two legal
choices giving up the queen for the
Knight or sidestepping with King G1 if
White had gone King G1 can you see The
Knockout blow for black leading to a
mating pattern pause the video to solve
if you saw Knight H1 check
congratulations this allows the Knight
to remove the pesky White Queen on the
next turn Paving the way for a Checkmate
that white can't stop the next game was
played about a decade later in Madrid
Spain in 1933 between Spanish Countryman
Martin or Twitter Esteban and Jose Sans
aguado in more recent memory Fabiano
caruana won a game in an incredible
similar fashion referring to it as his
own or Twitter versus Sans
much like the previous example both
Rooks were sacrificed on the way to a
victory with the black pieces sansa's
first sacrifice was a positional one
opting to develop the Knight instead of
protecting The Rook on F6 it's so good
that there are those who believe it may
have been made up but will give the
players the benefit of the doubt
it's worth noting that ortuita
sacrificed The Exchange right back a
couple moves later the second Rook
sacrifice was much flashier showing deep
calculation and end game Mastery in this
position Sans found Rook takes B2
sacrificing the entire Rook with the
knowledge that in the long run the black
pawns would decide the game the moves
that followed demonstrated incredible
patience on the part of sans finding
four consecutive only moves to force the
promotion of a pawn
after the Knight recaptured on B2 Sans
played C3 threatening to win the Knight
and promote on B1 ortuita thought he
could sacrifice on B6 leading to a
drawish end game since after a takes B6
whitesnite could easily get to the
critical D3 Square allowing it to get to
C1 to stop promotion but Sans played the
beautiful Intermezzo C4 the idea is that
the Knight can't take on C4 since after
C2 white can't stop promotion and if the
Rook tries to save itself black can
promote as well
Black's best attempt is Rook B4 and if
white plays C2 too hastily black can
capture on C4 and protect the promotion
square but Sans sees all of this and
attacks The Rook with A5 or Twitter
tries Knight takes C4 leaving his Rook
hanging but can you spot sans's final
move that led to his opponent's
resignation pause the video to solve
thank you
that's right finally black can play C2
leading to resignation since white can't
stop black from promoting to a queen
our first online game in this series was
a rapid game between yancha stop Duda
and Anish giri which was awarded
chess.com's 2022 Game of the Year Duda
and giri were both chess prodigies from
their respective countries of Poland and
the Netherlands and both have been on
the top player circuit for a few years
no doubt familiar with each other's
styles of play for those not on chess
Twitter it's worth noting that giri is
known for his social media banter and
occasional Trash Talk Duda on the other
hand while still having a Twitter
account mostly lets his chess speak for
itself
after sacrificing a piece in the opening
and giri later sacrificing one back Duda
found the incredible Rook G7 check which
in itself was awarded the move of the
Year giving up the entire Rook is the
only way to force a mating sequence
after King takes G7 F6 check King H6
Knight G4 check King G5 Can you spot
whites only move that leads to force
mate pause the video to solve
that's right Queen F5 check sacrificing
the queen for a forced mating sequence
after Knight takes F4 Rook takes F4 the
king can't capture on G4 on account of
H3 mate so the King goes to G6 this
simply delays the inevitable as white
has forced mate after the discovered
check Rook E5
here he must have seen this line as well
and he resigned right then and there
our next game is the oldest of all of
our examples played in 1851 in London
England between Adolf Anderson and
Lionel kizeritsky some of you may know
it by name the immortal game
this was from the romantic era of Chess
long before computers or even modern
openings and techniques it was much more
of an art than a science back then with
the emphasis not always on winning or
losing but creating the most beautiful
games in the process this game is a
prime example the first Rook sacrifice
after a bishop sacrifice happened in
this position where Anderson played
Bishop D6 leaving both Rooks on Pres
he's a risky opted to take the g-rook
first then Anderson didn't bother to
save the second Rook either singularly
focused on the black king he played E5
hanging his other Rook with check
Anderson brings his King to E2 then
kizeritsky thinking he's out of the
woods develops his Knight with Knight A6
after Anderson played Knight G7 check
the black king is forced to d8 Can you
spot the final brilliancy in this
position pause to solve
if you spotted Queen F6 check well done
after the Knight recaptures it no longer
protects E7 and white played Bishop E7
checkmate
for those keeping track at home in the
final position black is up 21 points of
material this flourish of sacrifices
including both Rooks is why the immortal
game will always have a place in the
history books
our final game is known colloquially as
kasparov's Immortal played in WIC NZ the
Netherlands in 1999 Gary Kasparov faced
off against Vaseline to paloff at the
time Kasparov was the highest rated
player in the world above 2800 topalov
would have his best years ahead of him
becoming feed a world champion in 2005
and eventually reaching 2 800 himself
to say this is a great game is an
understatement many agree that this is
the greatest game of all time in this
game Kasparov managed four Rook
sacrifices how you ask well not every
sacrifice was accepted
in this position Kasparov spotted a line
involving a back-to-back Rook sacrifice
Rook takes D4 after topalov accepts the
free rook on D4 Kasparov played Rook E7
check black can't take this Rook because
this leads to a mate in four with Queen
D4 check naturally white avoids this
mating pattern and plays King B6 after a
couple more checks and a sacrificed
night we arrive at this position here
black is up seven points of material and
the engine gives a slight Advantage for
white Kasparov plays yet another Rook
sacrifice with Rook takes B7 in which
the opponent can't recapture due to the
threat of Queen B3 checkmate
the white pieces then start to chase
around the black king for a few more
moves and the game arrives at this
position
Can you spot the final brilliancy played
by Kasparov pause the video to solve
that's right Rook D7 Kasparov solves the
problem of his hanging Queen by pinning
the black Rook via sacrifice of his own
rook in this case black must accept the
sacrifice as everything else leads to
mate kaspara then picks up the black
queen and a rook so when the dust
settles it's a queen vs Rook end game
and tapalov eventually resigns
we hope you enjoyed all of these
beautiful ways to sacrifice The Rook
and that you might be presented with
your own opportunities to do just that
on chess.com
post your favorites Rook sacrifices in
the comments